is Kevin from the chess website calm and
today we're gonna be looking at a second
game that I played and it was actually a
blitz game so a little bit different
format but just kind of wanted to go
through a few more of my games and just
kind of talk about how I approach the
game and deer in the game what I'm
thinking in and how I try to execute
that plan so we'll go ahead and take a
look at this game started out just
before that's kind of what I always
start out with they responded with
knight c6 and I just developed as normal
he developed to pawn to d6 and so I just
continued pushing my pawns up I'm step
got two defenders on this pawn so I feel
pretty safe and right away black does an
unusual move and then any time I see
this I usually just try to develop like
normal not really sure if he's trying to
set the trap but usually from this I
know that he's not going to Castle
kingside most people you know if they
sometimes you'll see him move it - you
know f5 here but most people that
they're just going to do it to f6
they're gonna cancel Queen side because
this really isn't doing much for their
their King side development and keeping
their King side safe so from here on out
I'm really going to have kind of in the
back of my head and I'm gonna try to
attack Queen side in anticipation that
he is going to Castle queenside so just
keep that in mind as I play but right
away I'm just gonna continue developing
I'm gonna go ahead and push this Knight
out of here and see what he does and he
just kind of moved it
and I'm gonna go ahead and exchange
pieces here one it is a blitz game in
two I'm gonna go ahead and have him
double up his pawns and I want to see
exactly how his structures gonna look if
he takes with the F pawn obviously now I
know kind of what he's gonna do so he
takes with with his D pawn and so we're
just gonna continue I bring out my my
bishop and I have my pawn here on d5 so
I can attack this c6 square twice and so
I'm gonna try to kind of break up his
Queen side as well since his King side
is already a little weak so he brings
his his Bishop and blitz games more so
than normal games all exchange pieces a
little a little more quickly so we went
ahead in exchange and I'm just gonna go
ahead and Castle kingside
I have a pretty good setup here good
central control my pieces you know they
haven't gone in any random places his
setup is decent but spawn structures not
the best so right now I feel like I have
the edge he's gonna Castle queenside
which we kind of thought was gonna
happen any time one side castles King
side one time castles Queen side a lot
of times it's a race to see who can
checkmate the King first so right away
my new game plan is tried to checkmate
the black King it's no longer set up and
I structure everything all my queen side
pieces are now going straight at the
black King and he's probably gonna start
pushing on my King side so I ride away
push up my C pawn and he tries to break
up he's got double pawns he was gonna
try to break up his structure
and I'm gonna go ahead and just bring my
a3 pawn here I really don't want him to
bring his bishop into the action right
now I'm not too worried about this pawn
being taken so he's gonna go ahead and
take it I'm gonna take back I was he
can't take because I've got protection
here so he continues to push this and
he's weakening his King said more you
can see that but I've got so much
pressure here that he's gotta do
something about it
so I just developed my knight normal
play here and he decides just to push
forward and you can already see his
king's head it's getting pretty weak
here so right away my king side is
really safe so I feel pretty good about
this so far I go ahead and bring my
queen into the action and he's gonna
push his his pawn here obviously he
doesn't want to give me too much room
you know bringing my queen or my my
knight in here but you can see every
move he kind of continues to weaken his
his King safety so I'm gonna go ahead
and develop my bishop connect my rooks
here my Brooks can kind of roam freely
on this on this first row here which is
always a good thing to do with your
Brooks and he brings his knight here
obviously you can't bring his Knight to
f5 and he wants to kind of put his
knight here and kind of obviously he has
a threat of coming out here he can bring
his queen down here and I'm just gonna
just push my pawn up these small
preventive things that you can do what's
your pieces can sometimes do a lot he no
longer he can't move his knight so he's
gonna have to eventually move his Knight
back right now we're not gonna worry
about it we're gonna go ahead and put
our rook on this semi-open file black
doesn't have a pawn on this file and
where she can put here so we can kind of
push this pawn down blacks throat
he brings his knife back into the action
he's probably gonna have to use this
night to protect on this side so we're
gonna go ahead and bring our queen
obviously we can have some discovered
attacks if we continue to push this up
and he brings his Queen here so actually
like the Queen back may have wasted
moved there but I like the Queen better
in this position and he starts to move
his King a little bit and now we're
gonna get our knight involved and you
can see I'm really starting to slowly
put pressure on attacking his keen so
and he really hasn't done too much to my
king my King's pretty safe and his Kings
under a lot of attacks so I'm gonna go
ahead and start pushing up pawns and
he's going to ignore them so I'm gonna
go ahead and bring my knight up here
brings his bishop into the action I'm
gonna go ahead and bring my rook so both
my rooks are very active here one of his
rooks isn't doing anything so I feel I
can have an advantage of that he brings
his knight here we're gonna bring my
bishop here pinning his his Bishop to
the to the night and he's gonna start
his attack on the King side and I'm just
gonna put an extra defender to this
Bishop and he brings his rook to the
d-file now I'm gonna go ahead and
sacrifice a little bit he takes and then
I'm gonna go ahead and take this piece
basically winning an extra piece right
here he can't take obviously because I
have my my knight defending so he moves
his Queen I'm gonna go ahead and double
up my rooks along this open file so
these groups are just bearing down on
him he's gonna start and attack on my
Kings side some more I'm gonna go ahead
and I'll kind of want to I this f5
square if he'll let me just because it's
a great outpost and you can't really
push it away these rooks are gonna have
a hard time getting to it and this
Bishop can knock it out so that's where
I am going to go
and I'm gonna go ahead and trade off and
then I'm gonna go ahead and start
trading off pieces I kind of calculated
real quickly that I'm gonna have a
winning endgame here so he's got a trade
off and then I once he trades off here
I'm gonna centralize my knight here and
then he pretty much offers hey do you
want my queen here and his King is
pretty much out of the equation and I
pretty much realized here that if I
trade off I can pretty much go blow up
all his pawns and have a winning game
obviously he's got five pawns and I have
six and I feel like having pretty much
gobble em up and if I need to I can
pretty much put all my pawns on light
squares so his Bishop can't touch him so
I go ahead and trade off and after he
trades I start to centralize my king
first I made my night out of the way I'm
not too worried I can always take back
on my pawn and I'm about to gobble up
these pawns of my king so then I move my
knight added protection he takes that he
can't take it with his Bishop because my
knight and now I just start gobbling up
pawns here I did you see and I don't
really worry about that too much then I
just start pushing pawns up the board
there's not much he can do here as you
can see I kind of moved money and then I
just get a I just basically maybe sooner
than I need to but I'm just gonna go and
get the Queen and make him give me his
Bishop and from here as you can see it's
pretty much easy game I can push either
of these pawns up the board and it's a
very easy win for me so this is one of
my blitz games hopefully you can take
some of the things that I look for in my
own game
and apply them to your to your game so
hope you guys enjoyed if you haven't
checked out the website soon recently
I've put up some more stuff on there so
it's just the www.hs website calm if you
haven't subscribed please subscribe and
I'll see you guys next video